come on honey take the slag out my dick
tuck
back and i'm trying that
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god hi
[Music]
[Applause]
this will be part two of our series of
walking with her
you're so bad at this
you have to be like oh my god hot you
have to you have to do it i'll throw it
down voicemail won't be heard
no omg highs please you gotta be white
with it just be white with it
okay these are voicemails that are from
actual listeners and
they call the line 1-818-533-1843
and you've got to say one beer he's all
about i am off also
all right this is our first voicemail
coming up asking george a question
yeah george how you doing man um
i have a question the question is a long
time 22 years
and my wife will not have sex with me
anymore
i don't know what it is but it's been
it's 22 years
at least a year and a half since we've
had sex you know i don't know i've tried
i've tried and tried but she just won't
do it okay that's a
thank you that's a good i don't the guy
didn't have to leave his name
um you know we were just talking about
that
yourself uh brian you and your wife are
just brand new relationship right
yep uh well we've actually been together
10 years okay and
sexually you guys are fine well she's
been pregnant so we've there's been no
sex
for uh geez a year okay let's ask this
are you one of those people that
cannot have sex with a person that's
pregnant i was when i was
when i was married uh i really i just i
couldn't do it
so i'm gonna go real deep here so we we
did ivf
right so i i i'm like i don't want to go
ruin
ruin my kid you know
yeah he was born in a hail storm
sorry honey but i'm telling everybody
what we do but yeah there is no sex in
this house until after the baby's born
no kidding so so the second she
like knew she was pregnant nothing
nothing
wow and and to be honest she she's the
one who's like yeah let's let's do it
i'm like no
no like i i i don't want to poke my kid
in oh my gosh that's hilarious no
listen i think that's you know there's
two thoughts i mean there's only one or
two you
you don't do it and then not finish so
because i think it destroys her
self-esteem because
you know some people think that women
are their most beautiful when they're
with
child that the gift of
creating a life inside of you is a
wonderful thing
you can also believe that you can also
believe that
uh someone would be of the mind of to
not have sex like what brian just said
i would be of that mind and um
how about you i i don't think you could
have adhered to that no i think we would
have
i think we would have had just just as
much if not more and how long have you
got how long have you been married i've
been married for 18 years
okay that's huge when you have somebody
at home that
is your partner and after you know 20 22
years
she doesn't want to have sex they
haven't had sex in a year and a half
ladies
your man is going to go somewhere else
so um the remedy is to make him
feel like your partner and not like he's
there to pay bills
or to be at your beck and call when
people get married
what attracts them first is they're
attracted to each other
now 20 years in if you stop
becoming sexually active for a year and
a half
it's gonna go two years and a half and
then you'll end up sleeping in different
bedrooms
and then it'll all come down to
that guy when he does get busted or
it's not going to end well that doesn't
end well i think a question we might
have asked that guy
if i had a chance is uh are you still
getting along the same as you did a
couple of years ago when you were having
sex because i mean that's a big deal
as the marriage goes on
everybody still has a role to play and
it's time to spread bread that's what i
say
okay well said artistic even all right
moving on
hey george this is leo i just wanted to
call and tell you about um
my mom married she passed away about a
week ago
that's why the one thing she always
liked watching was
the george lopez show and she really
enjoyed it very cool
even on her last night with this um
my sister asked her you know do you you
wanna watch tv she's like
she nodded yeah you want to watch george
lopez and
she's not a yes again and you know it
brought her some you know
happiness is always something she loves
watching i just wanted to thank you
you know that she had your comedy to be
happy towards the end
all right thank you very much well
listen i i
i first want to say i'm sorry for your
loss um
someone's mother is uh you know you know
i get along with your
mom very well my mother loves you uh i
haven't gone in for the tongue yet
we're both single only because you
haven't tried i told them i was going to
be a step dad but your mom
has always been very nice to me yes she
bought her a louis vuitton purse
which she's very very very proud of and
still i didn't get any from that one i
thought that was for sure
she said hey if he thinks i'm going to
spread bread for this
yeah so um yeah man
my condolences and i can't tell you how
you know touched i am that that the show
would have brought her uh comfort and
laughter
um because you know we forget sometimes
that people
are living real lives and they do suffer
loss when my
uh my grandmother uh passed at the
hospital there in sylmar and i walked
downstairs and people saw me and they
said oh if we take a picture with you my
grandma just
had just passed and i and i did you know
i did because it's kind of
what didn't it well it didn't help me
get through it
but you know if you don't you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like some of those
people on instagram right now
so you see that you know um you try to
make you try to make a place for people
but uh i appreciate a call like that
yeah
that was touching yeah he said we're
still going live here let me we're live
on live let's get ready to go someone
wanted to see the can yeah i can't
remember them
all right hey show me the eyeball too
the eyeball's great in there we'll try a
ball
what else you talking about here we go
all right come on all right number three
please sorry oh my god
hi george hey this is gregory
gregorio from big d dallas big d
hey calling to see if uh you're a uh
still average to john smoker
can you make a recommendation in a uh
potentially a uh churchill length
chingon vatto yes cigars
uh you have to be careful with this well
because uh i think
um they all have their place no woman
likes to smell a
uh cigar smoke at least i haven't found
maybe a couple
yeah a couple but uh cigar wise there's
some great padron is all
a fantastic company they they gave me
some when i was in miami padron is good
also baker roman julieta that's not
that's a dominican
uh churchill that's a perfect cigar for
that
but if you want to get into smoking
cigars or you are into smoking cigars
get a cigar aficionado or subscribe to a
uh
or to the magazine and every every month
they send and they have their
recommendations there
and it's good delicious thank you
everybody for tuning in
on uh ig live was it fun yeah i think i
hope they enjoyed it i was bored if they
didn't [ __ ] no
no no they're but yeah great people
brian they love me i know god bless you
i love you guys too thank you
let's do another one what the hey
oh my god hi so
like i have this problem um i don't care
about
farting in front of my girlfriend and
she thinks it's pretty gross i have i do
this thing where i wake up in the
morning
and i just i just [ __ ] hold on
i just let her rip man and she's like oh
that's so gross
but i think it's normal what do you
think better up than in george
hey i don't think that's i don't know
man dude that
that sounds like a [ __ ] like
your roommates
right i don't think i don't think go
ahead that's a great that's a great
relationship question
all right brian i mean i got to ask you
you've been with your wife for 10 years
correct
10 years yeah how long was it before you
farted in front of her oh god
i'm not kidding about uh two weeks two
weeks yeah those two weeks yeah
in front of you how are you guys okay so
so uh
uh that that i think probably took about
two years yeah there you go it's way
different right
i'm not kidding i think it was like
literally two years oh my god that's
awesome yeah
now it's like she dutch ovens me all the
time now she's laughing because
that's that's true love right there
that's awesome sorry
and women's farts let me tell you
something
and one time ann farted and damn man
you know it's different when a woman
farts because
a man will be like i ain't never going
down there until i get the all clear
sign
there's a lot of uh there are a lot of
things down there that could go wrong
i don't know i think like when you when
when your girl farts in front of the
first time it's hilarious you think it's
the cutest thing in the world that
george even talks about
this and at first it's the cutest thing
in the world
they've let their guard down finally
it's very cute you ever walk into a room
where they farted and you walk right
through it
oh that's like a goddamn different silk
curtain
that's what they should call the silk
they're like don't come over here you're
like why the hood this [ __ ] floated
how can [ __ ] be invisible that's what i
want to know the smell of it
we'll have to ask our crack science team
on that one somehow there should be a
scientist that can create
sparkles in the air that you know not to
go into the room
if you see blue you know little blue
dots
you know when they're pregnant they
blame the baby they're like oh the baby
he just went and just went and you're
like oh yeah the baby just went yeah
yeah there's nothing like a fart with
some with some [ __ ] placebo coming
through
oh hey now what did i call it oh a fight
with some placenta
coming to a ladies school
that doesn't make you hungry you're not
human there's something rapid
[ __ ] that's coming out of your waiter
we'll be right here for you
so yeah that's not so you guys do or
does marcy oh yeah
marxy throws down but but i mean i've
been together for 20 years now i mean
that's been a while but like i said at
first it's like hilarious and after a
while it's just
whatever it doesn't matter but the first
one is classic
because it takes them longer you guys
are guys
yeah we'll just let it rip they they're
very particular about that
yeah my daughter and uh
my daughter uh and her husband they
still don't and they've been together
for
12 years they still don't is a
relationship is
uh is a relationship better because you
don't
but that's a very rare thing i i think
that there
are rare occasions i remember one time i
went to a party
i think i talked about this in my
stand-up and uh i forgot my sunglasses i
always forgot my sunglasses and i went
in the car and you know when you're not
going to do it at the party
and you get in the car you're like that
[ __ ] came out
and you and and somebody knocked on the
window and they're like roll your window
down you forgot your sunglasses
like those aren't mine and you know
clearly they were mine and i rolled them
down and i smell a [ __ ] [ __ ] i hear
when i say call police because somebody
shaded my car while i was in the party
look i think if you can blow it up like
that if you can blow it up that's true
love right
really anything but when you can when
you drop it down you're open you're open
you don't you know what's funny is i
hear there's no secrets anymore
no um do you hide your underwear
i did well i still well i mean i won't
let her see it i mean i'll roll them up
where do you put them i put them in the
same place i just i just make them make
sure i do the lighter here's two stories
uh big boy who's on the radio in los
angeles oh he's great i've known him for
maybe 30 years and we made these tour
jackets that
on the back side of massachuan printed
great jackets like almost like working
jackets
and then it said ftp on the front so so
big boy i got big boy one
and he came down to nokia when i was
performing there and i handed it to him
on a hanger and he put it on and he put
his hand in his pocket and he pulls out
my underwear with [ __ ] all over him
because i hide him in the pockets of my
jackets
and uh he goes i swear to god oh my god
he goes gee is this you and i said oh
yeah man let me have that
like he wanted him back oh that's
awesome he just and casually he didn't
go like jesus christ he knew he picked
it up and rolled up in a little ball
and uh he said this ug and then he still
wore the jacket god bless him and took
it with him ah
that one and when in the early 80s we
met this guy who was a little
more cultured than us bobby ergon he's a
fire chief here in los angeles
and uh we went to one of his parties
where they didn't look at us
you know fondly it was in granada hills
and we're from san fernando mission
hills
and guillermo gonzalez uh who was my
best friend growing up said
at two o'clock he made like a basket of
hard-boiled eggs
and we went over to his house and he had
old english 800
and some sunny delight and he's like
i'm like what the [ __ ] is this and he
goes this is what we're going to eat
right now
and then we're going to go to that party
and we're going to [ __ ] crop dust
everybody's the first time i've ever
heard crop though
oh my gosh so we ate the we ate the
hot hard boiled eggs drank sunny delight
and then finished two uh tall boy 800
old english 800. and oh there's some
jokey old english
on the car right over there we were
gagging each other
you know the thing and we got out and we
would walk up in conversation and we
would say yes
you know what's interesting is because
near northridge there's a place and then
just
and then just step away and maybe you're
five feet away before they go god
and we were just cropped dusted a party
that it was a party not for us
but the idea of crop dusting gas at a
party
oh god once again the recipe for anybody
that's listening
a basket of hard-boiled eggs um
sunny delight and two tall
cans of old english 800 and let the
pedals fly
where do you even buy old english 800
anymore like i've never
even seen it like 7-eleven no
you got to go to the castle almost like
the black neighborhood 812 you know they
got like you know
the knockoff markets yeah yeah they
don't have bonds they have john's
right yeah you shake down a homeless guy
yeah it was rough that's that was rough
it's going to be close to where you can
cast your check
and buy liquor and change your baby in
there oh my gosh
no that's an interesting route you drive
by uh liquor
and checks cashed oh yeah you know it's
a disaster when you see that sign
right i used to get my checked cash when
i got paid from uh delivering beer
and they would it was they're selling
alcohol and then you would have a
800 check and they would reach their
pocket roll out a wad
pull out a wad of four thousand dollars
and give it to you
and not worry will you tell them would
you tell them because brian has had
brian kellen at superboy comedy brian
kellen has had
pretty much he sold sperm tell me what
you saw sperm i give mine away for free
but you sell yours i say yeah i sold it
uh in college you know did you ever hear
about that yeah i did yeah oh it was
awesome
i mean in my college newspaper it said
sell your sperm and make like 110 a week
or something like that i'm like wow
that's easy enough so i did it for i did
it for years it was amazing you got you
got a hundred kids now
yeah i'm probably serious that movie
with vince vaughn right where he hit all
those kids yeah i'm
pretty sure you know what i don't when i
don't break your bubble butt
they show the picture of this of the
sperm donor
before the woman picks a sperm and if
you see this
[ __ ] honker right there you're
going to be like
no yeah like i actually have no kids it
turns out
no one no one checked yet it's almost
like that [ __ ] yogurt that they try
to move to the front when the date's
gone
and nobody's buying it and they just
[ __ ] put it back in there you know
you know some
girl some organization where they give
it to you know convalescent home
they don't mind eating dan and yogurt
you know a month and a half past the
expiration date
your kid's going to sell fruit but yeah
so uh walk me through the process of
of how someone would go about selling i
mean sperm
so you call in all right and you first
of all they give you a massive
uh physical before you're going to check
it and get everything dealt with but
then you walk in what you do is you
drive
to century cities you walk right in sit
right down
and drop a big load of sperm
that's exactly what it is so you go in
there at first it's embarrassing you
walk in there and you're like oh man i'm
going to just
do my business like an everybody first
it's embarrassing so you walk in there
and they have what they call we used to
call them the masturbatoriums so there's
like a bunch of like
like almost fitting room type things oh
i i did ivf trust me
you know i'm very familiar with that all
right that one's next
this one's first go ahead so okay so
then you walk in there and they have
these little rooms and they're awesome i
mean if you're
i was was 1920 and they had on the walls
all kinds of porn they had like all
kinds of play but whatever you wanted to
look at to get yourself they but they
send you
a little cup with a lid on and they're
like just make sure it all gets in there
kind of thing you know so
you do your business you walk out and
every walks out and no one has a problem
with it and at first it's really
embarrassing
but by the third time you're high fiving
dudes like what's up what's gonna be
good what do you got you got you ready
i'm ready
let's go it's great and then they they
make sure you have a good batch
and they pay your money was there a day
that you went like at the same time
you know people go down to the flower
mart in la every morning like you can't
get there at seven
is there a day flowers yeah i always
went after my biology class i don't know
whatever reason that was the best time
for me
my biology lab in college i just took
off from my car and i knew no one would
know i'd be gone for very long
i think my football practice like
started later that day or something like
that so i just
hauled ass to westwood from the valley
and then i would come i went to csun and
then i would come back and
refreshed ready to go go matador magic
exactly
exactly that was great but you had to
stay you had to abstain
how many times would you say that you
sold the uh sperm how many how many
sessions i did
yep nobody have to say
maybe a hundred maybe a hundred i think
so yeah well more than that probably
maybe two hundred
i was on a program [ __ ] insatiable
yeah so what so what was your sperm
count
do you remember i i don't know average
sperm count well you had to
reach a certain level i know that the
minimum was like i don't know what good
or bad
20 million really i don't know but you
had to be
above us you had to reach a score
because they obviously had to have
a lot of swimmers in there so so they
they they make sure your level's all
right so a lot of people don't pass a
test surprisingly
so i was one of the lucky ones and you
can go three times a week
at most do you think that it's always
the porn stars that are a little goofy
looking like this that have the biggest
rods
oh yeah like sometimes a good looking
dude you'll be like oh i
cannot see but then a guy like this you
know he's got like a [ __ ] cuerno down
there you know
[ __ ] louisville slugger on the side
of it yeah my favorite word
my favorite [ __ ] night stick
one time i was on a plane i was and
before we got to play but i i
sent my my wife a picture of myself we
were on a trip
and i said i don't know how he got a
hold of it but he's on the plane
is this you like what the [ __ ] how does
that happen i thought it was a bird
feeding a worm to a little bird
but it was not it was brian and uh okay
all right alleged pylori and that thing
i think caught the light
you know your dick is big when it
catches the light it looks like two
different colors
oh god wow this is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
rotisserie bob over here
this guy's got a massive [ __ ] horn
taking a turn
and he hasn't trimmed his bush forever
yeah yeah you can't you can't when
you're married because your wife's like
what's going on down there
i've been married for 20 years they
can't just like you know escape it and
she's like
uh well they think they're like you're
cheating on me why why are you
landscaping all this
exactly right usually it's called
manscaping but
see the ship behind him that's part of
what he that's part of what's going
between his legs in the back all that
[ __ ] shrub back there
we need to get a video of that like a
[ __ ] octopus
the octopus professor if i took my shirt
off this is what it would look like
that's my background yeah okay he's
still very sexually active so getting
back to the guy's question
after all those years i think it's time
to have a heart-to-heart discussion with
your old lady yes
as opposed to seeking um
um action somewhere else because no good
will come from that
you're right and you're eroding your
marriage and if you care about her
sit down and have the discussion with
her and then how's the how does the in
vitro uh situation
it's not easy no no it's it's it's uh
look thank god it's there right because
people do have issues it's very it's
very difficult it's extremely emotional
and uh you know the thing is nothing is
guaranteed and it's also really
expensive so
you you start out in this process by
uh you know the guy's easy let's we we
pretty much they say we need your sperm
let's go to
you go to the uh the office and they
open a door for you
a real short little funny lady smiles at
you she gives you your little cupboard
and she goes i'll see you in a minute
and then you say okay you walk in and
there's a computer with porn all over
red
red tube they have red red tubes their
default like that's the porn star they
like
right you got red tube going on and then
uh
they just say you know get your thing
and hurry up and the problem is there's
all these people whacking off right next
to you
so you can hear it in the other rooms
because the walls are there so you're
like how do i concentrate so that's the
worst part
but then the girl oh man guys the for
the female it's
it's really emotional like they uh they
have to have their their eggs taken out
and they
they put them under anesthesia and then
they they take the eggs out and then
when they fuse the eggs and the sperm
together which happens
kind of quickly what could happen is you
could spend all this money at that point
put your your wife or your significant
other
under all this scrutiny and then it
could not fertilize
you know you could get nothing out of it
then you got to do another round oh man
and age has a huge
factor for women to do it you know once
you get over you know 35 years old
it becomes really really difficult and
why is that why is that because
their body changes um as you get older
you don't produce as many eggs
or so a woman i learned this through the
process so a woman is born
with all of the eggs she's ever gonna
have so if you have a daughter
right she was born with every egg she's
ever gonna
have and they shed hundreds and
sometimes
thousands of eggs per month and you only
have one so it's kind of a miracle that
any of us are born
because you only got this one egg so by
the time they get 35
after that it just starts declining how
many eggs are actually
good so you're searching for that one
golden egg
so for example you could have 18
eggs retrieved and when you fuse them
together
only one or two could be good and for
some people
zero devastating oh wow so if you go in
there like one time and they
harvest these amount of eggs and they
try to
match the sperm of the egg and it
doesn't work can you come back next
month next year in six months or is that
that
no see so you can keep coming back you
know you can come back a month later if
you wanted to restart the process it's
very expensive
very expensive but what happens is the
it's hard on the woman because they're
putting all of these
synthetics and needles like you're
you're just the onlooker as the husband
or
or the significant other i should say
right and you're
they inject themselves with all these
massive hormones to grow and stimulate
their ovaries and the eggs
and for them it's just you know they
can't eat certain
foods they get bloated their their uh
ovaries start hurting because they get
too big with all the eggs
so you you probably want to wait a few
months but yeah you could if you if you
really
wanted to go in you could go the next
month over but at one point
if it's just not working then that's the
sad part you know the doctors say hey
you do it this way the good thing is you
have adoption you can carry other
people's eggs these days
but yeah it's a hard process wow well
congratulations
for getting it done um
you know um yeah they have a surrogate
that uh my theo got a girl pregnant and
and my theo said you [ __ ]
you're cheating on me and he said that
that's surrogate
you donated it and she goes
she's not using my egg i i took one from
the refrigerator
when you were sleeping i went over to
bar store and i got it
by the roy rogers museum
it's the horror vast climactic of the
[ __ ] bath clinic of barstow
so anybody that's trying to do that god
bless you because you know i have one
daughter
and uh and lucky to have her
so it is expensive but
you know um bringing a life into
this world with somebody that you love
is and then
you know you can't imagine that you
could love anything more
than golf but i do so yeah my daughter
uh mine is is great and i always thought
i'd have more than one but if
that's her i'm happy to have just her
all right she did well amazing she's
amazing she's a great girl
all right well let's do some news uh
there's her first one from bbc.com
mother used deep fake to frame
cheerleading rivals
do you guys know what defect is i don't
even know what that is okay rafaela
spoon from pennsylvania
uh united states reportedly sent the
content which showed members of the
victory vipers team naked drinking and
smoking
to the coach so deep fake uses
artificial intelligence to doctor images
and videos oh man
so she basically put their faces on
naked images and sent them out and they
were they were
girls who rivaled her daughter who was a
teenager
right that's rough yeah miss spoon is
also accused of sending abusive messages
uh to the team their parents and owners
of the cheerleading gym for fake phone
numbers
so wait a minute that's somebody's mom
that did that
okay listen if we're gonna get into this
artificial intelligence [ __ ]
nobody's gonna be safe right because a
kid can do that which they almost can do
it already
and you start to look at those things
they'll have me and you blowing each
other
huh no they won't well at least that was
a little claim it's fake
that was fake i swear to god it's
artificial intelligence
that has no bush that's a fake how'd you
know that well all right it's fake
yeah right i think you know i remember
when i went to facebook
years ago uh and they gave me
the app to facebook live before anybody
had it
a month before it was out and they and
they presented it to me and they said
be very careful uh we're giving you
something that no one has yet this is
gonna be the biggest thing
so you could go live but also
you know don't make a porn and don't
leave it on
when you're you know and i had that i
had that in my
in my phone which i don't think i really
i was a little afraid to use it because
it is a lot of you know
but i think in the hands of a teenager
where you can start to throw faces on
different people and create stuff like
that where you could send to the police
yeah and get them to arrest somebody
yeah uh
you know possibly be aggressive with
them and it's all been kind of
made from this artificial intelligence
right yeah that's crazy how wicked
is that of a parent a parent parent who
did that that's a competitive woman
right there
oh my gosh that's ridiculous but it's
really hard but
is way overweight she says she is
cheerleader she's hispanic
she's never
[Laughter]
can we get away from the word trailer
trash because every trailer you see now
has water hookups and electricity i
don't think we're talking about these
days trailers
all right so anybody out there lives in
a trailer uh
even though it says like you know tahati
estates
um it's not what it used to be what you
would consider that it smelled like
peanut butter and jelly you know
which is uh they'll have phones in there
and they wear shoes
but they were shiny because i grew up in
a trailer you don't know this right you
don't know this
i grew up in a trailer in new mexico it
was a nice trailer
nice one of those was that double it was
a double double
is it one of those where it's 114 in the
living room and [ __ ] 98 of the
bedroom
yes bathroom's freezing yes because you
can't get the whole thing one
temperature
yep and if someone flushes the toilet
when you take a shower it scorches your
back
oh yeah hey that transitions well to
this story
this is from whdh.com a man is facing
charges after he allegedly stole a 400
pound slide
from a playground and mounted it on a
bunk bed in his home
his home trailer oh man 400 pounds
maybe he's in close by i'll go with it
right now he said dustin allen bushnell
30 of burbank washington was arrested
tuesday on a charge of possession
of stolen property according to the uh
pasco police department
uh executive julie lee was investing in
a series of catalytic converter thefts
when evidence letter to bushnell's home
police said they still steal catalytic
converters
huge it's huge right now all hondas are
in danger
right seriously hondas are if you park
your hana outside uh garage you're in
trouble all right take it easy sorry
yeah my neighbor just got like pogba i
know exactly i'm a little fired up
but uh lee suddenly came face to face
with a gigantic slide
which was reportedly stolen in december
of 2020 and she searched the home for
catalytic converters
bushnell sawed off that slide repainted
it and mounted on his bunk bed in a
child's bedroom at his mobile home
so that's what this dude did he
repainted put up a 400 pound slide in
his mobile home which i'm sure was a
little bit bigger
listen i want to [ __ ] re take back
what i said about mobile homes
and trailer trash you're back on bucket
trailer trash here open that one right
there
oh yeah all right let's pass it around
yeah we'll take a break
but but but uh what what do you think
economically put somebody in the trade
like when you guys were growing up like
what were you poor or what how did you
end up in the trailer that that's a
really good question right so so
no like to us we weren't poor like as a
matter of fact the community i grew up
in
we were the rich kids it is that sound
weird people thought we were rich and we
actually grew up
we were rich they really they grew up
they were rich so so
yeah so essentially what happened is it
was just the easiest
fastest way i'll tell you you're gonna
you're gonna laugh my mom is gonna laugh
at this and probably be pissed off
she's an attractive lady yeah no my
mom's amazing right she's a great
woman my mom is very beautiful but she
so what happened is so my my grandpa
you know wanted to get her her own house
because we were staying at my
grandmother's place
right and she she just they were
fighting my mom and my grandmother you
know mother daughter rivalry
and uh my grandpa's i need to get her
out of here so he literally just
found a trailer like in two days and a
piece of property
and just bought her the trailer and said
here you go my mom was 20
i think she was 24 years old at the time
right here you go that's where you're
gonna live
she landed just living there and
converting the trailer into a house but
that's that's how we did no one else in
my family ever lived in the trailer but
us
isn't that interesting but the community
we're in was so poor
that we were the rich kids that sound
weird how long did you live in
the trailer uh so we lived in the
trailer for
about 10 years and then still
still lived in the trailer but they
knocked
parts of the walls down and turned it
into a house that's crazy
like they made it into a house but it
was still at its bones a trailer isn't
that crazy
yeah it's still there it's still there
still still up there and still going and
you own it i mean and we own it and we
rent it out
isn't it right now it was an amazing
gift then yeah it turns out
yeah it totally was but isn't that i'm
telling you again the strangest thing to
me is
we never thought we were poor because in
the community we're in
they were like you were the rich kids
wow isn't that strange
um awesome you know there's some there's
something to be said for that because i
think without
social media and without people trying
to
you know be more than they are in real
life
making you know with filters and things
like i was telling you that people
uh like i'm almost 60 man like i haven't
been in high school in 40 years
and you know anytime somebody's upset
with me they attack like the way i look
how i'm aging and i'll bring up the
stuff with
my wife and it is [ __ ] like
high school to think that these are
adults that don't have i'm probably sure
they do have something better
but just but do you think that a comment
that
i'm never gonna read satisfies you
that you've even sent it that you're
taking time
out of your life which is time is the
one thing we can't make and then you
choose to either attack me or leave me a
negative comment does that
really kind of make you feel better does
it make you feel like you're a better
person than me does it make you feel
like you're good you know you have kids
is that an example to send
to people that you're responsible for
their upbringing that somebody
who's an adult would attack another
person worse than if someone was in high
school
i mean is that and unfortunately that's
where we are
as a culture not only remember politics
was something no one spoke about
but your comment is not gonna change the
way i feel about
my politics or change the way i feel
about people which
uh let's forget most of you guys are
wrestling fans and in the trailer that
wrestling
isn't real and it's created and just
like entertainment
this isn't real you know i don't really
act like this i do
in real life wait this is real but this
is probably
the most real i've been but you know
i can't thank you enough for supporting
me
or i can't ignore you enough when you
don't it just doesn't matter so
at some point people that leave comments
not just for me but for celebrities
they don't give a [ __ ] man they don't
care we got all this [ __ ] to do then be
[ __ ] scrolling and looking at what
you're writing yeah all right next what
else
all right well speaking of how does the
guy get that slide though in his [ __ ]
room about it
so he cut it off he cut it off of a
local
and instead of playing around he used a
[ __ ] big red come on
probably right and he welded it in he
i welded my dick tucked back and i'm
trying to hide
[Laughter]
yeah he's not like this in real life
everybody come on honey
take the slag out of my dick tuck back
and i'm trying to hide
that's an original brian espinoza is our
guest
create a song oh man i think that's a
good one
that's a good one come on honey take the
slide i got my knob
tucked down and i'm ready to hide
all right good all right all right this
one comes from cbsnews.com that sounds
real
this high school announcer blames
diabetes for racist remarks towards the
girls who kneeled during
national anthem yep what about girls at
neil
after later on okay so
so this one the guy used the n-word yes
he did yeah she is you all know this yes
and you know did he lose his job
you know it doesn't say whether he lost
his job he must have lost his job but
they didn't say but also anybody who
is an announcer who thinks that when you
go to commercial you really have gone to
commercial
no those games don't last long enough
for someone to
forget that you know they're doing this
as their profession
and you know it didn't serve imus well
and
you know it just creates well i wouldn't
say that it creates
something that is surprising to anybody
unfortunately so that guy should lose
his job because you're there to
um announce a game that
hasn't you know you're announcing the
game as it happens
and your job is not what you would
consider the surgeon general's job is to
[ __ ]
uh diagnose people from the [ __ ]
press box
yeah good point it's a real good point
and the fact that he just went there
though
and he was on a live mic he didn't think
the mic was live so what happened was he
he just said this stuff he's all f them
i hope they lose he said
if they're going to kneel like that hell
no and then he called him the n-word
video uh on a live broadcast and we
shared it online
oh he'll lose his job no he's dead he'll
lose his job and
he'll be announcing [ __ ] spills that
wiggly piggly whatever the [ __ ] that
name is
well you know there are things that are
acceptable and then there's things that
just aren't right
and that is not acceptable right it's
not you know you can disagree with
people
and have respect that guy whenever
somebody turns a mic on you have to
assume that
it might be live but when you have no
respect
then you shouldn't be in a position uh
like that
well the thing is too he didn't own it
at all let me say something
i didn't know tom landry thought tom
lambie was an amazing coach
and when he got fired by jimmy johnson
and jerry jones
what's beautiful about this guy and you
know most people probably don't know who
he is
he always wore a hat had a coat and he
was he was like stone
man and even vince lombardi
or paul brown or john madden
or you know um all of the great cope don
schuler those guys
had decorum they had respect
and none of those guys ever went
there and if you if you think that they
didn't get to where they got to coach
at a pro level without some bias towards
something but they were there to coach
players not to divide players
and you know respectfully tom landry
took
that firing which was a huge
embarrassment for him and took it like a
man and
and walked off yep classy as he always
was you know now
you're if you're joe paterno and
somebody comes to you and says hey
you got your your your offensive lineman
is he's going for
some end route to the shower and um
um that again was something that
as beloved as he was and people
supporting him
which you could understand the act of
what was done by sandusky
eliminates any of the good unfortunately
that was done
by this wonderful incredible coach
as a coach yeah and they took down his
statue and they covered it up
and they removed it because in this
climate right now
when it was in your heart and you never
said it you didn't take it away from
your heart
but as these things happen now and
things are are
revealed then those people have to
suffer the consequences
yeah and again he didn't he didn't cop
to it at all so it's not like he
apologized really he's i will state that
i suffer from type one diabetes and
during the game my sugar was
spiking are you kidding me no
let's read the statement the sugar is
spiking they're having a [ __ ] scooter
pie
while he's doing the game he's during
the high school
school basketball game amazing i'm
surprised i don't haven't lost a leg for
diabetes
oh yeah they were [ __ ] great malo
mars and moon pies oh my gosh
hey listen i could put a scooter pile in
this [ __ ] roof right now come back
tomorrow and be [ __ ] 12 of them up
there
don't forget about those little debbies
those little debbie's oatmeal cream pies
man
i ate a box of those i bet your little
debbie was little when she [ __ ]
started the company
they don't call them fat ass debbies for
nothing and now
the the pie that every from cankles
the coffee cake that that that everybody
knows from junior high
somebody told me the other day that they
know somebody that makes coffee
reuben that makes the coffee cakes that
we all ate in high school with the crust
around the edges that's what he said
yeah
found a guy who makes him wow if you if
you went to school in uh
los angeles yeah that reminds me of like
romeo and michelle's high school and i
invented post-it notes like how do we
know that's true
exactly right like from the monkeys
yeah his mom invented white out right
yeah i thought somebody from watts would
have invented whiteout
okay that's the little okay
um all right we'll move right along how
about that move along see oh this is a
good one too
this is one of my favorite ones because
this is un freaking believable are you
bothering me
i'm buzzing like crazy i'm buzzing like
your cousin this is from
the pasadena star news.com uh panda
express workers forced to strip
in cult-like team building seminar
which panda express yeah well it's the
one here i think wait a minute it's
orange county register so it's it's
it's around here yeah in santa clarita
so if you work for the panda express
where they go in there
so so what they do yeah they go in there
and they line you up and say all right
uh orange chicken drop them yeah
shrimp fried rice yeah it's a lot like
this
drop the grin and and drop the linen
well done a former uh employee of penn
express and santa clarita alleges she
was required
to strip down to her underwear and hug a
partially clad
a co-worker during a cult-like ritual at
a 2019 training
seminar sponsored by the company as a
prerequisite for a promotion
oh that's just whole school man yeah
that's so they they what they do is they
hire these these like
like drill sergeants and make you feel
like horrible about yourself and then
they make you strip down and they laugh
at you in the whole nine
years they say bring your fraternity
again geez yeah yeah a live
seminars and coaching academy in a third
party organization
which panda has no ownership interest
over which is exercise no
says a statement from company while we
always encourage encourage personal
growth and development panic
express um has not and does not mandate
that any associate participate in a live
seminars
so basically what they're saying is
they're washing their hands with it but
they put them in this situation where
they all got in a group
and they yelled at them and said you're
nothing to us and you get to strip down
to your underwear and you gotta hug this
other guy and this people are crying in
there and this is for panda
express this is not like you know
they're saying like they have chin chin
i'm having chin [ __ ] that probably
hit you with some [ __ ] noodles in the
back oh man
tie you up over a pipe but like pulp
fiction they're in there
oh man not to work out
front [ __ ] boston market boston
market that's why they went out of
business they pulled a dude out with a
two holes
ah there's a [ __ ] rod hanging out
we're thinking we're thinking about
opening it up about opening a new
location in lancaster drop them
ah that's all a ledge that's all the
legends i'm gonna go to sleep with that
song in my head
george step aside butch
oh that's classic the guy who was
getting bow and have a band-aid on the
back of his head ball-headed
i'm going to do some medieval [ __ ] on
his ass what did he say
uh all right well that was a that well
first of all
what do you think of you having to go to
to anything like that you
should you for pandxpress have to do
anything
any kind of uh team building no look man
i'm tainted
i was in a fraternity in college you
know what i mean what's the worst thing
that made you do
oh yeah you know that's a good question
let's see it really wasn't that bad i
would say
the scariest worst thing they made us do
was the night that
we got our pledge pins right
they um
[Laughter]
about the stables every night at 4am
no we had to uh we had to uh
uh basically you're going to go run down
uh the street and your boxer shorts
right right
this is a night you get pledged your
hotel's going on and you got to run a
half mile down the street
to its sorority row which is just down
the way from us and
you're like it's not that bad it's you
know midnight 1am no one's going to be
up it's a sunday night
and uh you you run in your boxer shorts
you do your little fraternity chan you
drop your boxer shorts
put them on your head and run back home
oh [ __ ] right it's called the dude run
right and so you're thinking you're
thinking it's one o'clock anymore and
what you don't know is that
all the sorority girls have been waiting
for this all semester
they know about it so when you get there
they have like
like a stadium built with all these
women with video cameras
taking you right so you go you drop them
come up and then you have to go serenade
them
a week later and the second you walk
into that room in all the story houses
they chant we saw you naked and they
have pictures
like for me they show up when i get to
introduce yourself like it's a gentleman
and the second i walk up there's a huge
picture of me naked
dong hanging out everything all right oh
man
when you say you got a dog
[Laughter]
that's like you know listen i gotta call
it a dog because it's massive but it was
team building you know that's they said
this is team building you know did they
at least
were you low uh hammered a little bit
were you drinking pretty no no no that's
that's the crazy part is you are dead
so dead sober when you do that right
that's rough
but uh no it's uh so so for me i'm i'm
all about team building exercises
some people maybe not yeah i don't know
man that's that's uh
that's quite a bit of a thing i think it
brings you closer
but you know maybe if you had like a mom
and pop
and maybe the mom takes her bra off like
hey kids i'll show you something that
you
that you won't ever want to have anybody
connected to these
tits and she just drops them and their
[ __ ] nipples are fighting they look
like you know
they're fighting they're finally like
miss butterworth dripping down the side
of some pancakes ugh
oh man right
are we talking about that because
there's nothing uh that's awesome i
don't know so would you have done it
would you have done it
would you put that challenge on your
head and run around when i worked that
fedco would have done it yeah
yeah i would have done it you ready but
also that was a time when you didn't say
anything
you know yeah well i mean just
i mean just pure embarrassment would be
the only reason that you wouldn't but i
mean yeah that's a tough one
yeah you heard that you want to be a
part of that but you had a great
experience with a fraternity
great great experience honestly but you
know i got to tell you like
you're you're best friends but also
fraternity in specific and i'm sure it
will relate to the workplace
your best friends come out of that place
and so do your worst enemies oh
right that's interesting best friends
and worst enemies yep
and that's also where nobody had video
cameras and stuff like that right
so that's when they just started coming
out like
the the phones with cameras because this
was 2002.
okay and that's that's just when like
samsung started with the
little video camera but it was photos
like these people had these massive
you'd see these women with these massive
professional cameras with the zoom on it
in their room oh
that's rough yeah that's rough cause you
find a picture can i put it above that
tv right there
yes if someone will produce that photo
if someone's out there and you produce a
photo anybody that we talk about that
has embarrassing photos and if they do
appear
yeah we're going to put them right over
that area right there and anybody who
like is willing to have it posted up
there has to have a dong
i mean i mean you're going to be proud
of it you're like hey you can put my
naked picture i would never have you put
my name
see back then facebook didn't exist
there was no social media
oh yeah that didn't exist and that's the
key now is that's also immediate
back then you just you couldn't get it
out like that and more power to the
punch that once they you that was a real
picture yeah but we had to produce that
oh it was a real picture yeah but i
don't think that in in a time like this
where you know everything is social
media and if you put it up there
this is what young people don't believe
uh
and you know years ago when barack obama
was
just elected i think in his first maybe
year
he was at you know used to be on cnn he
was
at a at a uh grade school in florida
and he was getting ready to leave and
you know he asked if anybody
wanted to ask any questions and the kids
said you know if i want to
be president what should i do you know
at this age and you know you know he
said
he said be careful what you put on
facebook because once you put it on
facebook you can't remove it
and if in 25 years enough from whatever
or 40 years when you said run for
president that's still going to be there
and they will
pull that up and use it against you
and it might be something that you know
there's people that have tried to get
out of
uh workman's comp and they post a
picture of them dancing or post a
picture of hawaii we're not supposed to
be there
and they lose you know it's fraud
anyways but you know they undo
themselves because
you know they have to let everybody know
on facebook what's going on in their
life
yeah there's all that facial recognition
they post it up there and like hey
brian kellen's supposed to be at work
today and there's brian kellen right
there at a baseball game
it happens all the time yeah no either
you or a [ __ ] condor showed up in a
[ __ ] shirt
speaking of sperm uh insider.com
scientists want to send 6.7 million
sperm samples to the moon as a global
insurance policy
have you heard this at all no that's
interesting though yeah it's very decent
all your loads that nobody wanted what
did you do just floats around space
perpetually there's some bird-like
culture
they're developing cultures finally a
payload of that [ __ ] we want to get
rid of yeah right
uh scientists had suggested that humans
could buy into
modern global insurance policy by
building an ark filled with 6.7 million
sperm samples on the moon
the ark would involve shooting the sperm
that's part of the expression hey all
right
and ova samples of 6.7 million species
up to the moon via multiple payloads the
sample would then be stored in a vault
beneath the surface of the moon in a
lunar pit
if you think there's some ugly
[ __ ] out here when you
when we reject our bad ovum and bad
sperm to the moon
what do you think those [ __ ]
will look like
they'll have [ __ ] suction cups coming
out of their [ __ ] back
they'll look human but you know some
[ __ ] that washes up
in [ __ ] marina del rey that has like
a man's head but a [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] stingray body you know of
course somebody
[ __ ] the towel and threw it in the
water and a [ __ ] stingray swallowed
it
i love that expression you know how many
[ __ ] towels you don't end up in
[ __ ] bubble gums
somebody eating a [ __ ] man
oh god i [ __ ] it
man you know i don't go to the sizzler
anymore but i'm sure i ate a couple of
[ __ ]
samples over there that malibu chicken
with [ __ ] malibu they're telling you
oh man but uh it's all kind of batter do
you use
you'll find them [ __ ] guy with a
[ __ ] mouth on the side of his head
is that the end i'm from the moon yeah
that's our last story i mean it's
basically uh
we're doing this to make sure that if
any natural disaster happens
i don't think we should do this because
listen the moon is beautiful
and every everybody in space the soviets
and everybody tried to you know land on
the moon whether we did or not
it's up to debate if you're a conspiracy
theorist person right but
you know let's not [ __ ] with the moon
let's leave the moon as it is once you
send it to saturn or
something you're right or jupiter or
some [ __ ] out there just
you know what or don't even or just say
the [ __ ] morning just shoot it in the
air and
once it breaks the atmosphere just
[ __ ] mecca will float in a circle
forever
the rain the rain smells funny no it's
out there the rain smells like clorox
oh yeah uh yeah well i i like to know
like
i would like to know who would decide
what samples get to go
right you could talk to jerry springer
all the special people that get along
and you send them up into the moon
well i think i think you decide by you
know um
whichever ones nobody wants right like
the trash i don't know if it would be
right i mean wouldn't you want it like
if you're if you're
you're wiped out by an asteroid down
here you've got to start this all over
you some someone's got to have some say
in who's in there
right yeah what was the name of that
movie that elijah wood was in and uh
uh morgan freeman was the president what
was that oh what was that legally
sobiewski was in it
yeah yeah the same thing like they
picked and chose who
oh yeah you're right yeah the government
will choose if they think you're you're
a person who
you know uh will add to rebuilding the
culture that's whose sperm goes up
yeah right see yeah scientist sperms
everything you know athletes all of them
yep george lopez sperm go up there for
comedy
we need good entertainers let me know i
gotta call carolina
not to wash those towels and they got to
go to space
but why was tyler going to the after to
the tour to nasa
as part of the crema institute beautiful
and that's a good man that was our news
man you've done a great job today brian
you thank you you're still learning
though yeah whatever i still
as entertaining as a [ __ ] blister but
you know i couldn't i couldn't have done
it without you
god bless you my best friend of the
whole world
thank you everybody for listening in to
oh my god hi
who are our guests our guests were brian
espinoza
executive producer of walking with herb
and who else
and uh ross marks the director of
walking with herb
and we thanked them greatly they were
awesome he was actually
not in the studio but he was with us as
well i didn't get a chance to drink our
delicious beer i hope everybody gets a
chance to uh enjoy this movie it's
really good
and great job brian thank you for being
a champion of the film man
absolutely as well this is a great one
thanks for having me on guys
i had a lot of fun today so if you get a
chance to be a guest on the show
take it you're going to drink some good
free beer that's right
if you get a chance to
see anybody naked take it all right
everybody we'll see you next week on
oh my god hi
you